le gouverneur ici bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors vous contester cette décision en
justice au nom du libre exercice d'un
mandat parlementaire pour vous ce droit
de visite doit s'exercer en dépit de la
crise sanitaire
oui il doit s'exercer surtout parce
qu'il ya la crise sanitaire se sont
notamment parce que il y à des
circonstances exceptionnelles que nous
sommes fondés à venir contrôler ce qui
s'y passe parce que c'est pas quand tout
va bien que vous pouvez visiter une
prison et vous dire ah bah oui c'est
vrai les conditions de détention des
détenus des conditions de travail des
personnels sur les surveillants les
personnels administratifs c'est
précisément dans ces situations de crise
où nous avons une utilité une plus-value
notamment aussi pour faire remonter tout
type de dysfonctionnement que nous
pouvons constater sur place au
gouvernement
lors de la mission d'information qui est
consacré aux côtés de 19 lors des
questions au gouvernement et c'est donc
c'est c'est précisément dans ces moments
là que nous avons une utilité c'est
pourquoi j'ai fait valoir effectivement
devant le juge administratif
le fait que je puisse aller visiter en
prison croire et vous savez
l'administration pénitentiaire la
ministre en l'occurrence a fait un
mémoire en défense puisqu'ils ont été
invités à se défendre et nous avons ça y
est obtenue le jugement du juge qui a
statué à un non lieu
c'est à dire qu'en fait l'administration
pénitentiaire va dire pardon monsieur le
député c'est vrai quelques vides 19 mais
bien sûr évidemment pouvez visiter la
prison ce qui était quand même pas le
premier intentions de ce qui m'avait été
communiqué et par là par
l'administration pénitentiaire et le
juge précise que effectivement je dois
si je viens je dois venir avec un masque
et c'était à respecter des
gestes-barrières mais ça semble évident
mais il m'a donné raison puisque la
négociation potentiel et la ministre
nicole belloubet a cédé à la même
d'ailleurs été condamnés aux frais de
justice par là par la même occasion ce
qui est aussi un petit signal envoyé au
ministère de la justice en disant pour
écouter il ya des libertés fondamentales
qui ne qui ne doivent pas être entravée
et il ya des tas de gens qui rentrent
dans les établissements pénitentiaires
les avocats les prestataires extérieurs
qui font les frais
de marchandises de nourriture etc je
suis pas sûr que un parlementaire qui
qui plus est respecte les gestes
barrières et porte un masque ce soit une
problématique sanitaire majeure surtout
quand on voit comment ces panneaux mis
en détention alors il ya les
parlementaires qui ne peuvent plus se
rendre dans les prisons les visites
aussi aux familles sont interdites en
fait l'ailé les visites des familles des
détenus est ce que c'est trop stricte et
est ce que cela peut avoir des
conséquences également sur la vie de
tous les jours pour pour ses détenus
mais ça ça a énormément de conséquences
parce qu'en fait ce ne sont pas juste
les parloirs qui auraient été arrêtés
c'est toute la vie sociale au sein de la
prison c'est à dire l'école pour ceux
qui avaient des cours c'est ce sont les
activités socioculturelles c'est la
salle de sport ce sont même les cultes
qui sont arrêtés à tout est arrêté en
détention ce qui fait que vous avez
objectivement en maison d'arrêt les
détenus qui sont 23 heures sur 24
puisqu'il ya une heure de promenade par
jour 23 heures sur 24 dans leur cellule
et souvent entassés à deux ou à trois
dans neuf mètres carrés donc ce qui déjà
est peu supportable normalement parce
que mais bon vous y arriver parce que
des activités vous sortez un peu de
votre cellule
là ça devient extrêmement extrêmement
compliqué donc c'est pourquoi je
souhaitais effectivement aller voir
comment ça s'organise on nous dit qu'on
vit de la prison je voulais je voulais
le constater on nous dit qu'on met les
personnes confinées qui ont des
symptômes du cobp ide dans des cellules
seul je voulais le voir aussi comment ça
s'organise bon voilà on nous dit que les
personnels pénitentiaires ont tous des
masques tant mieux je voudrais aussi
pouvoir le constater
et d'ailleurs je vais pouvoir le faire
puisque la ministre a cédé et je compte
bien me rendre à la prison de sequedin
pour pour constater tout ça sur place
petit bémol quand même pour l'instant la
nôtre supputations ne souhaite pas c'est
leur formule 1 et ce ne serait pas
souhaitable que je sois accompagné de
journalistes
je m'interroge quand même au regard de
la la liberté de la presse et d'un
certain nombre de libertés fondamentales
le fait qu'on le demande de venir seul
mais de toute façon
j'exercerai mon droit de visite
parlementaire très bien merci beaucoup
ugo bernalicis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct sur rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes député la france
insoumises du nord